il est huit heures du matin
c'est parti pour le tournage d'
assassin's creed assassin's creed non
allez donc le costume d'assassin que je
porte dans le clip c'est un costume qui
a été créé par un cosplayer amateurs par
chance ce cosplayeurs exactement les
mêmes mensurations que moi c'est à dire
je mensurations de lâches les gros fail
d'ouverture le pire assassins du monde
qu'est ce que c'est la bonne idée de
mettre des petites pointes sorte de coup
à l'intérieur on regarde tout le
mouvement je me voilà pour moi dans le
clip est un peu le rôle style et du mec
hip hop qui apparaît pour faire des
blagues mais j'avais quand même un peu
chier à cause de cette moustache que
j'ai tout le monde a dit on des nvic
mister vie quasi non toutes les images
du clip sont tournés au château de
fontainebleau l'architecturé bonne pas
mal l'univers assassin's creed pour les
passionnés d'histoire c'est un château
car qui était l'une des demeures
favorite de france un 1er mai je pense
que françois 1er est jamais allé dans
les endroits où on allait ayew a
travaillé avec la french free run family
j'ai absolument voulu
faire le clip avec eux parce que c'est
un mec là des boîtes c'est vraiment
hyper impressionnant ce qu'ils font
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que moi j'ai
fait du parcours quand j'étais petit à
bondues parcours un peu amateur 1 mais
j'allais faire les flip la semaine la
plus lisse d'europe voilà le jour il
faut avoir justement des crampons j'ai
déjà glissé deux fois avant d'aller sur
le toit j'avais pas du tout envie de
glisser sur le toit et de mourir d'un
cocasse et j'assume je vois ce que je
veux dire la première fois que je tourne
avec autant de figurants tous habillés
avec des costumes d'époque j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'être immergé dans
l'univers assassin's creed j'avais
l'impression de jouer le verrou quoi
limite on vous pose une question je
faisais attention les faits et parle on
l'a acquis moment tu peux relever et on
est un petit peu
j'avoue je me plains pour un must h mais
norman avait lui une fausse calvitie qui
mettait environ six fois plus de temps à
être mises que la moustache et en plus
ils pouvaient pas du tout bougé quand
torturé avec rien faire je dois bouger
ces convois les freerunner dans la vidéo
faire des figures évidemment c'est
impressionnant mais on se dit qu'on peut
au moins tenir debout sur un toit bah
non c'est impossible mais mettre debout
sur le toit c'est hyper flippant que
voir les gens faire le parcours j'ai
peur on est vraiment dans quoi c'est ce
à quoi ça sert bien quoi tu montes sur
les toits de paris ça aiguise la
curiosité
jusqu'au moment où tu te fais chanter
par les flics j'ai l'impression d'être
un gros hors la loi alors qu'on faisait
juste une vidéo life on est quand même
déçu par la loi les plus gentils du
monde
on leur a montré nos vidéos et ça les
fait marrer assassin's creed accord
vient enrichir soit déjà c'était hyper
périlleuse faire un tournage fenêtre
paris super dangereux flippant en plus
il valait concierge de l'immeuble qui
gueulait mes volets pas juste nous faire
descendre
je pense qu'ils vont nous faire
descendre et nous tuer
et
on a fait aussi appel à certains
cosplayeurs et cosplayeuses qui sont
venus avec leurs propres déguisement en
fait à la fin on a fait une sorte de
grosse battle hip hop puis au milieu il
y avait les freerunner qui étaient des
figures la même aussi j'ai fait des
acrobaties assez incroyable
évidemment ce clip c'est avant tout une
chanson et la musique a été composée par
nos des ja en plein de talent en tout
cas je tiens à remercier tous les gens
ont participé à ce clip vidéo et puis il
est en squeeze qui a accepté de
participer à ce délire voilà à bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo ou alors pour
autre chose ou alors pour encore autre
chose
je crois qu'il ya certains textos qu'il
faut surtout pas recevoir canton
notamment ce fameux tu fais quoi
messages reçus à deux heures du matin
par un numéro inconnu tu m'explique